all right looks like we're now live for
the May 2023
AMA session
um internet is lagging a bit here so
hopefully we're not going to have any
real problems don't have any control
over how the internet works in a big
city here like Milwaukee there's a lot
of construction Happening Here in the
downtown and that can always lead to
issues but I see we've already got a
question lined up which I might have a
bit of a disappointing answer for from
and Olivia do you have any opinion on
John Milbank or postmodern theology more
generally so John Milbank is somebody I
haven't really thought about since about
the
mid-2000s you know he's associated with
The Radical Orthodoxy movement I've
actually seen him at the American
Catholic philosophical Association
presenting years ago
and I read through his book
um Theology and social theory wasn't
super impressed with Milbank or the
other Radical Orthodoxy people which
include Philip blonde and Catherine pick
stock and uh I think Graham Ward
um you know I kind of get what they were
up to which is trying to react against
what they view as
post-modernity and and go back to
something that they're you know
resuscitating out of the Middle Ages but
I never found their project all that
compelling
as a matter of fact I actually did a
book review of The Radical Orthodoxy
reader years and years and years ago but
I just never found what they were doing
all that compelling and I you know even
though he was quite laudatory of Maurice
Blondell I found that Milbank didn't
actually know what he was talking about
when it came to that so that makes me a
little less trusting of him as a scholar
post-modern theology I think is a
category is to you know top level
abstract to be much use uh because uh
you know if you ask well what is it what
is post-modern
ask 10 philosophers get 10 different
answers I mean that's part of the
problem with using these these category
terms like that
um one person's post-modern
post-modernity is not the other person's
post-modernity or post-modernism or
stuff like that so I I don't usually use
that use that much as a category myself
so I don't really have any opinion on
postmodern theology more General
all right uh black prairie have you
heard of Noise music if so what are your
thoughts what philosophical worker
thinker can help draw the line on what
music is at its most basic so yeah I
mean I've heard of Noise music I don't
really listen to it because I've got
some fairly narrowly defined tastes that
were formed largely back in my childhood
teens and 20s you know
um and you know there's there's so much
music being produced out there in the
present that you can't really stay on
top of of too much of of anybody unless
you pick a particular genre so I don't
have any thoughts about Noise music you
could just say not my scene uh my scene
is primarily classic metal with some
other stuff you know uh you may have
seen me remarking on social media when
Gordon Lightfoot died a couple days ago
you know
um that uh I play his stuff as well
um what philosophical work or thinker
can help us draw the line on what music
is at its most basic I I don't know
um I I think there's
a number of different philosophical
thinkers who have very interesting
things to say about music but I don't
know that there's like a particular
person who I would pick but I'm not a
I'm not an Aesthetics person you know so
maybe there might be better people to
ask I mean we know that an ancient
philosophy we already have Plato and
Aristotle reflecting in rather crude
ways about music we know that there's
this guy cenos who is a student of
Aristotle who wrote A trees on on music
I think we've got bits of that left
and there's a lot of other philosophers
along the line as well you know who who
are doing interesting work all all the
way through the the medieval period like
boethius Has A Treatise on on I think on
Harmony
um you see Reflections by Augustine on
music and then you know we go all the
way into like you know say the 19th and
20th centuries and you know you could
think about uh Nietzsche and his his
remarks uh in various works but I you
know I don't know that there's like
somebody who has a
the definitive take on music but maybe
there is because I don't I don't really
work in that area
all right so Mark says hope you're doing
well thank you for doing what you do
look forward to these amas I'm glad that
that's the case here's the question been
listening to thinking about some Ronnie
James Dio songs lately I know you
respect him any comments on his legacy
or influence on you
yeah you know Dio
um
he was somebody that I I listened to in
high school I actually freshman year
went to the record store bought Holy
Diver brought the album home and my mom
was really mad because you know it's
kind of the the devil throwing uh or a
devil throwing uh this priest into a a
dark Lake that's the Holy Diver on the
album cover and she was not amused she
actually tried to take the album away
and I was like well let's listen to it
first and then then she was okay with me
having it
um
I think in part because she didn't hear
any satanic uh songs on the on the uh
the album Dio is he's he was the
smartest guy I think in the field of
heavy metal and that's saying a lot
because there's some pretty smart people
doing work very observant you know able
to like carry on interesting
conversations with people and not just
talk out there proverbial Bots or make
the wrong kind of generalizations you
know when you when you look at Dio and
the interviews that he does he's very
judicious he's thoughtful if he's got
something he's got an initial take but
it's wrong and somebody points it out
he'll change it you know so I I think
he's he's also a great showman and he's
somebody who has uh a real sense for
let's let's just call it the virtue of
Justice you know everybody getting what
is their their doom and you know he's
very
um willing to acknowledge where he
learned from somebody like he says you
know Richie Blackmore taught me about
Showmanship and
um you know gave me this opportunity to
be with rainbow which then leads to you
know two albums well three albums later
with uh Black Sabbath and then his solo
career where he brings in these amazing
talented musicians and I've actually
I've met people who've worked with do
and they talk about him as you know sort
of like what we would call in in
Aristotelian philosophy the architect
the architectone the master worker who
regulates everything else
um apparently he could play all the
different instruments he stuck to voice
but yeah so I look at him as an example
of somebody who in you know in the a
particular field was essentially like a
philosopher a really good philosopher
working in an applied field where you
had to produce something so
yeah so that's that's probably enough
about you know going out about Dio but
I'm always happy to talk about him
uh Tony James do you have a favorite
Aesop Fable I don't I don't think I
could say that I have a favorite Aesop
Fable
um I don't remember too many of them
it's been you know going back to my
childhood since I actually read through
them so that's that's kind of a pass
Abraham uh where do you suggest one
starts with early Christian philosophy
with the early Christian philosophers
right so great example would be
lactancius we have
um several works by him he's pretty
early Justin Martyr another really
important early guy uh Clement of
Alexandria you know unfortunately with
some of these thinkers we don't we don't
have like everything that they they
wrote but we've got a good good amount
and these are all people who
who had a really great basis in the
available philosophy in Mediterranean
and near Eastern culture
and we're trying to articulate
Christianity this you know new religion
um in dialogue with it Clement of
Alexandria actually goes so far as to
say that for the Greeks Greek philosophy
is a preparation for the gospel the way
that the Hebrew scriptures are for for
Jewish people
um
you know there's you you probably also
sooner or later you want to read
Augustine obviously but you don't want
to jump like way ahead to him I think
he's somebody worth getting to John
Cassian for understanding monastic life
obviously of agrius ponticus who's
preceding John Cassian very important
thinker as well and there's there's more
but I mean if you spend time reading
those guys
um it'll it'll take you a while and
it'll be it'll keep you pretty busy
there's important theologians who we
also like bring into philosophy or have
stuff to say about philosophy like
tertullian and origen right so all of
those are are important figures
um Ben have you read Mark Fisher I
haven't read Mark Fisher
um so the rest of it's kind of moot
um for those of you who don't know Ben
Fisher is a
here as to unfortunately uh died a while
back if I remember right he killed
himself and he was uh thinking about the
horizons of of capitalism I mean maybe
I'll get to
him this summer I don't know if I will
but I'm going to be pretty busy
uh Ben or Marco rather what are the
metal bands whose lyrics you enjoy the
most that's a that's a really
interesting question so
um
I mean I think that they're basically
the same metal bands that I keep
circling back to over and over again
even if their lyrics aren't always like
if you take their lyrics by themselves
they don't always make as much sense
without the music I mean we talked about
Ronnie James Dio Dio was a master
Lyricist you know
um you look at that first solo album
there is not a bad song on there and all
of them are like really interesting
lyrically obviously Iron Maiden you know
um Judas Priest Motorhead
um
you know I I uh I like the Scorpions
they're you know writing in English even
though they're a German band
um and some of their lyrics are quite
interesting if you think about what's
being said particularly when you go back
in their catalog you know to the Uli Von
Roth uh era you know from Flight of the
rainbow up to taken by force
um
I mean who else tank you know they've
got some really great lyrics including a
song that chokes me up every time that I
hear it about the death of a child uh
beneath a frozen River
um
yeah that's a good question I mean and
and we could also ask another question
what what really makes for Good lyrics
you know they have to they can't be too
wordy right they can't be too
thoughtful because then you're you're
not doing lyrics you're doing a
dissertation or something they got to
fit in with the music but they also
gotta you know they gotta lead you
somewhere right so
all right uh Elijah says Blondell
discusses how fear deprives one from
pursuing what one wants in discussing
self-mastery of Vitality does Blondell
have similar discussions anywhere of how
anger deprives one of Happiness
um I don't think so and I I think he's
probably just using that as an example
um Blondell is as far as I know it
doesn't
it could actually there is a work of his
that I haven't read where this could be
the case he's got a a work that's never
been translated from the French about
mysticism that is a little hard to get
your hands on
but you know you don't see blown Dell
spending an awful lot of time discussing
the affects or emotions as such
um
I mean it's usually in the context of
something else right it's not like he
focuses on that just by by itself
uh Erickson Brown why do you believe in
God complicated reasons I'll just leave
it at that
um
Jeremy do you think language is an
innate capacity we're born with well we
have an innate capacity for language but
language is not a capacity language is
what we do with the capacity
uh Yoda do you believe do you think
mathematics is objective truth and does
it exist outside the mind I mean I
wouldn't identify mathematics with
objective truth as it looks like you're
doing here but mathematics is a you know
what's what's in mathematics is
objectively true and Mathematics is a
field a literature and a vast vast set
of propositions
um and you know it depends on what you
mean by objectively true that's one of
those words like I mentioned with
post-modernism people like think that
they know what it means and then you
throw it around but you know there's
different senses of that term out there
and does mathematics exist outside of
our minds sure why not I mean
that doesn't prevent it from being in
our minds there's an interconnection
between our minds and other uh things
that that are real you know our minds by
the way are real too
um
logike can science give fully certain
conclusions or only very probable
propositions
boy you're gonna not like this one there
is no such thing as science there's the
sciences and to generalize about them is
extremely unscientific I would say to
lump them all under one thing called
science
um you know it depends on what you mean
by science if you're thinking of
mathematics as a science well doesn't
mathematics give us certain and
necessary conclusions sure seems to but
is mathematics actually part of science
or a science
um and then you know when it comes to
the sciences that deal with this world
out here or the human mind and Society
uh pretty much all you're going to get
are at best probable conclusions and a
lot of times just speculations right
so all right
um
and Olivia any advice for trying to talk
some sense into a friend who's become
more drawn to conspiracy thinking or
extreme political views in recent years
um not a lot because you know if you
think about why did they get drawn into
that it's going to be because it
satisfied some deep-seated psychological
needs and desires that are not going to
go away by you just bringing things up
um so you got to figure out what's
making this person tick and there's also
going to be like a whole community of
people out there that they've bought
into uh who are saying to them you're
not the weirdo you're not the one who's
who's off base you're not the crazy it's
all those other people out there so
you're gonna have a difficult time going
against both what's in the person and
what they're getting from the
communities that they're involved in so
I'd keep your expectations pretty low
um the best thing that you can do
if they're not too far gone is to say
listen
um I think you're wrong about this stuff
and you know I'm not into that and if
you want to hang out with me uh I don't
want to hear about your crazy conspiracy
theory crap
um we better figure out what common
ground we have or we're not going to
have much of a relationship because if
if you are doing this conspiracy theory
24 7 we probably don't have much in
common anymore and that can really suck
you know that that could be uh one
significant other it could be a friend
it could be a family member
um sometimes a colleague right but
that's that's kind of tough
um
Oroville says do you have any thoughts
on the different biographical sources on
Plato
diogenes Laertes Alice gallius Etc
should conclude Plutarch in there right
I mean everything we're getting is at a
distance but it's the best that we've
got so you know
we stick with that I mean
I'm not sure what you're what you're
asking about you know are we are you
asking whether these are reliable
or you know how far we should trust them
um and you could also say how much does
the biography really matter with Plato
you know for understanding his works you
don't you don't actually need to know
anything much about him as a person to
be able to read platonic dialogues and
get something out of them so
all right uh Leslie says love a gay man
like no other but he's been promiscuous
and may want an open relationship is an
open relationship doomed to deprive one
of Joy how should I think through
whether it's worth being open well I
mean first you got to figure out whether
you're cool with an open relationship
like you know speaking for myself and my
wife we wouldn't be cool with that uh if
she were to like you know and and I
doubt she ever would but if she was like
yeah you know want to open up the
relationship I'd probably be like well
that's weird that's not what you've been
you know into all these years you're
pretty focused on exclusivity so how
much does exclusivity and what goes
along with it you know
um the intimacy the security how
valuable is that to you and you also got
to ask what the other person so
why do you want an open relationship is
it just like you know you mentioned uh
you got a friend who wants to screw
around a lot is is that what it's about
you know are they like dealing with some
sort of existential crisis worried about
their own attractiveness I mean we could
go on and on and on but you know these
are the sort of things where you you
want to know what people's motivations
what their reasoning what their values
are and only then can you start figuring
out whether you would really be a
compatible
open couple or not you know
so I don't think there's much more that
could be said about that
um
all right let's see here
Sunny Folker
posting this a couple times do you know
of any ancient philosophers stemming
back who discuss and reason through
death in the notion of the afterlife
well Plato yeah I mean it's in Plato's
dialogues right
um Aristotle also talks about death and
you know the Soul on the body I mean
Aristotle thinks basically once you're
body's done you're done
um the stoics you know and the
epicureans both materialists talk about
the nature of death epicurus actually
has some pretty important Reflections on
on death
um so you know there's a lot of people
in classical ancient philosophy who do
think about the afterlife and then once
we get you know once we get to like
neoplatonism and
um you know Judaism Christianity flowing
into Mediterranean culture
um there's far more speculations about
what's what's going on when we die so
you know plenty of there's plenty of
philosophers who are
um
interested in that Bob what do you think
of lgbtq
LGBT morally I I don't even know what
you mean morally are you asking whether
it's okay for people to have uh
attractions that are not absolutely
heteronormative I'd say I mean first off
we know that's the case that people do
and it seems like people can certainly
have successful relationships you know I
mean I'll tell you kind of a funny story
when marriage equality was a big topic
you know and and there's oh should we
have gay marriage or not and people were
like oh this is going to cheapen
heterosexual marriage and I was like do
you understand that the divorce rate is
like 50 percent I mean how the hell is
heterosexual marriage doing good all
these people who are like you know oh
the Bible says blah blah blah you're
like evidently you don't believe
anything the Bible says about divorce or
about uh lost or stuff like that or how
you know married people ought to treat
each other because you're sure as
not practicing that
um worry about getting that stuff right
before worrying about anybody else's
stuff uh and I used to joke around
um you know why shouldn't we have gay
marriage let them be as miserable as the
rest of the the populace right
um so I I don't know you know that's
those are you got to be a bit more uh
specific when you ask about those things
um
all right skipped a little bit let me
grab some stuff by people that I haven't
already answered
so uh Sierra says I'm pretty new to
philosophy I have some books I've
started I find interesting but are
contemporary like Zizek should I start
with more basic background first or go
backwards I would never start with ziz
Jack I mean why would you put yourself
to that trouble I mean if you want to
read somebody who's contemporary there's
plenty of people who you can read who
aren't like spiraling all over the map
like some you know manic person
um whoever told you you should start
with zizak steered you wrong you don't
necessarily have to like begin at the
beginning with the pre-socratics and
then work your way forward
chronologically but you you don't want
to I mean I would no more start somebody
with Zizek than I would with Hegel or
dairy da or you know anybody else who is
you know dropping jargon all over the
place and not really providing many
explanations or justifications for what
they're constantly asserting
um you want to find people that are kind
of congenial to you you know
um
all right red stoic uh what's the most
useful practical Philosophy for daily
life besides stoicism depends on who you
are right there's no like
single answer for that sort of thing
um as many of you know I'm I'm myself an
Eclectic who draws on a number of
different Traditions including stoicism
and I draw on them because I find them
valuable for you know making sense out
of life and relationships and you know
our place in the universe or stuff like
that
all right Oroville says uh to clarify I
was curious which biographical sources
which were in your opinion most likely
true and which weren't and if they
changed the context of his work at all
no I mean I don't think that any
biographical Source changes the context
of Plato's work
um
because you know Plato's works are sort
of self-contained
um
there are dialogues but they're they're
interactions and and you know Plato's
laying out his philosophy
in them
I mean you do get some
what we could call doxography that is
the you know the history of
um
viewpoints or positions in in like
diogenes Laertes diagonies will say
Plato you know he said these things and
he lived here but here's the things that
he actually taught and believed and that
that can sometimes be interesting but
um you know what do we know with
diogenes there it is we consider him to
be kind of uninspired and you know
probably a second-rate mine but uh
presumably fairly faithful to things
sometimes maybe it gets his chronology
wrong but you know who are we to say
um
you know and we don't we don't have
a lot of uh stuff to draw and that's
that's close in time to
uh Plato right so
yeah I think that's probably all we can
really say about that
um
Fitter do you think that human logic is
credible certain and trustworthy and
objective
it depends on what you want to use it
for I mean
formal logic whether it's Aristotelian
or you know later modern stuff or you
know the stuff we can reconstruct from
from the stoics having to do with
argumentation it works to the degree
that it works you know I mean life is
not a matter of uh syllogisms constantly
and people don't generally argue like
that but it can certainly help you when
you do encounter an argument in the wild
as we say and I don't know what you mean
by human logic we have a bunch of
different Logics uh do you mean the
discipline of logic as developed over
the centuries that we teach like an
intro to logic classes
um I mean if you're asking that then I
guess the answer would be sure when it's
used on things that logic is is useful
for right sort of like saying um
you know can I use this cookware for
cooking everything well no different
tools for different tasks right
um I I don't know what credible would
mean there
um trustworthy sure if you're you know
if you're working with stuff that logic
is good at working with then it's
trustworthy and again objective can mean
a million different things I'm not sure
what that's supposed to mean
uh logic where do you recommend I start
if I wanted to learn analytic philosophy
so that's a really interesting question
um that's a tough one to answer
because if you're asking about like
who analytic philosophers would have in
common as like their Canon of people
that they've read
the answer unfortunately these days is
nobody you can't trust that people who
are working in the analytic analytic
tradition which is now over you know 100
years old have actually read the stuff
from from the early years of analytic
philosophy I mean they might have they
might not have they might have read it
uh in a
let's call it faithful substantive way
or they might have just glossed over it
right so you know if I were like going
to say take a historical approach to it
I mean and let's say I was doing this
for for a class let's say I was teaching
history of analytic philosophy which is
a class that I did take when I was um a
graduate student you know we would read
uh Fraga and Russell and
um more
and uh Wittgenstein you know we read the
tractatus and probably philosophical
investigations or uncertainty
um and then we would you know look at
some some later thinkers I would I would
definitely have them study John wisdom
along the way
and you know
um Gilbert Ryle and and now we're
getting into like you know the later
period you know I'll read Austin on
speech acts but the trouble is is that
you can't count on people in analytic
philosophy as a tradition anymore to
have read that stuff as a matter of fact
about 20 years ago people started
talking about post-analytic philosophy
because there were so many different
like subdivisions and they started
developing their own vocabularies if
they were Medieval Scholastics and
pretty soon they were not really
communicating across the the lines
anymore
so if you want to if you want to study
like contemporary analytic philosophy
there's like a million different
discourses that you could jump into and
I would I would say just pick one of
them you know depending on what you're
interested in I mean there's analytic
philosophers
grappling with all sorts of interesting
topics and even sometimes going back and
reading historical figures not usually
very well I would say but occasionally
saying something interesting so yeah
it's it's very tough to say the same
question could come up with like you
know where should I start with
Continental philosophy oh you know
that's a tough one too right
um
all right uh ridicule what are some
interesting recommendations you have in
the area of U.S history if any could or
could not be philosophy related I don't
really know I mean I I don't uh I
haven't spent a lot of time these days
Reading U.S history I'm mostly reading
primary texts and philosophy so I don't
think I I don't think I actually have
any good recommendations about that uh
tractatus do you think there are certain
philosophical questions that could never
be answered due to it being beyond the
limits of human cognitive abilities
um
I mean I
I don't think so
um
it depends on what you mean by answered
and you know what kind of questions
we're talking about and what makes them
philosophical
but I don't I don't see let me put it to
you this way let's rephrase it are there
any
questions that come up within philosophy
that cannot be provided with some sort
of answer
because of the limits of human cognitive
abilities and if you put it like that
then I would say no I mean we can
provide answers the question is are the
answers good are they bad you're never
going to get complete consensus in
philosophy or indeed in many other
fields on
um
those sorts of matters right so we don't
take a complete agreement by everybody
in the field the way you might and say
uh I mean Dirty Little Secret is doesn't
even happen in mathematics and and the
hard Sciences
um there's always going to be some
outliers who disagree but
I mean then you ask yourself are the are
the answers
reasonable answers
are they
compelling are they substantive you know
and then that can that can help you out
uh Ashmore did you read the New York New
Yorker profile and Agnes callard if so
what did you think of it what do you
think of the general reaction to it no I
didn't read it I just read like some
summaries of it I don't like Agnes
callard I think she's a grandstander and
you know seems like a terrible person uh
I think she like does stuff oftentimes
just to draw notoriety and I actually
blocked her on Twitter years ago because
I just found the stuff that she was
saying so
you know just kind of dumb really
um I don't I don't find her very
interesting at all I mean a lot of
people react to her and so you're kind
of stuck with the the dialogue and most
of the reactions are usually along the
lines of wow what a terrible person and
I think they're probably right you know
I don't know why people pay attention to
her other than she's got kind of a a
nice position and she's controversial
you know but there are some people who's
whose opinions I value who I do see uh
lauding her from time to time but I I
don't think that I think life is short
pay attention to people that actually
have something to offer you know
all these uh do you think that there is
one ideal political system or must the
system be adjusted to the cultures and
Society in question yes both I mean you
can have an ideal political system which
then has to be adjusted to the cultures
and Society in question and time and
other modifications
the ideal you know political system
would be one that is actually aiming at
genuine Justice and as somebody like
Aristotle points out that's got to be
recalibrated every once in a while right
and it should be broadly representative
um again something that Aristotle
pointed out in the politics you have
people making different kinds of
contributions they each deserve a seat
at the table you know so
I I you know I'm a virtue ethicist I
think that it would be great if we could
have more actually virtuous people not
just people who posture is being
virtuous or maybe like you know put up
charts on their wall about the you know
the cardinal virtues or silly crap like
that but you know don't live up to it we
want to promote real virtue but that is
so so difficult again attention that
Aristotle talks about in his his work
the politics particularly in uh book
seven if I remember right some
um
let's see here
Ali adwad has something kind of weird do
amas later earlier I missed this one do
another one soon
how could you possibly have missed this
one if you're writing in this one so
that doesn't make any sense whatsoever
and I do amas every month same time same
day Saturdays 12 Central it's up to you
to you know put that on your calendar
and then show up for it so all right Ben
says do you think it's wrong to
associate yourself with someone who's
committed heinous crimes in the past or
do you think if they've paid their debt
to society or that they're absolved it
depends on how they paid their debt to
society and did they are they still uh
you know dangerous uh exploitative
um narcissistic person I mean you could
pay your debt to society and still be a
complete scumbag that everybody should
shun you know so there isn't any simple
answer to that
um I mean to associate yourself with
somebody who's committed heinous crimes
in the past I used to teach in a Maximum
Security Prison you know so I had people
who committed heinous crimes and they
were my students and I associated with
them so obviously you can associate with
people right I went and uh testified for
one of them in a sentence modification
hearing so it really depends on has the
person fundamentally changed you know
you can have somebody who stays in
prison for 40 years
and really doesn't fundamentally change
um
no I don't know what this has to do much
with with Chomsky uh the the news with
Chomsky is that he had some connection
with Epstein but Epstein didn't pay his
debt to society Epstein was a disgusting
pervert who engaged in human trafficking
and basically got off scot-free because
uh he was connected to the rich and
Powerful I I don't see how that that
makes any any
um
sense to think about here I mean you
could say well if Epstein hadn't died in
prison and he'd served his time I mean
probably would have served life wouldn't
he if you actually if there was any real
Justice
um it seems like kind of a moot point to
me or did you have somebody else in mind
with Chomsky
um
all right uh
VV I'm a mechanical engineered by a
profession three plus years in the
industry now do you think philosophy has
any applications in engineering or any
uses for engineers on a professional
basis there's something called
engineering ethics that strikes me as
something where you better have some
philosophers because when the
professionals try to do it by themselves
they usually mess it up pretty badly so
yeah there's definitely something there
and you think about engineering uh it's
a teleological process oftentimes just
having a you know philosopher in the
room when decisions are being made will
help you by the philosopher actually
raising some questions and you know as
well as I do if you're an engineer that
you know there are there are professions
where people do ask
you know questions outside of their
little area uh quite frequently
engineering isn't one of them and um you
know there's a mindset that often comes
with it that that will frustrate the
smarter engineers
um but really satisfies the ones who who
aren't so yeah there's lots and lots of
scope you know and really any profession
when you get to its foundations or you
start thinking about it at a higher
level you are engaging in some stuff
that is philosophy and it might be
helpful to to bring in philosophers to
help out with that
um Oscar is the success of the socratic
alankas measured by its capacity to find
true beliefs were only as a tool for
dispensing false beliefs
um I don't think you measure the success
of it I don't think that's the sort of
thing that you have a metric for right
if you're asking is the benefit of it uh
one or one of those or the other then
it's you know by virtue of being alankas
that is refutation it's pretty much
about leading people away from false
beliefs but that's not the only tool in
the box right the Socratic method is way
way more than just asking questions or
contradicting people or showing where
they got stuff wrong by the way people
who say oh Socrates the guy who said you
didn't know anything
BS Socrates if you read platonic
dialogues or even xenophons dialogues he
knows a lot of stuff and he gets his
interlocutors to agree to a lot of stuff
even in dialogues where they don't reach
the final conclusion there's all these
things along the way that clearly they
know so I'd keep that in mind as well
uh Michael Virgin by choice but regret
it since I'm lonely considering starting
a casual and exclusive sex relation
since I'm in love what personal values
and motives should I consider when
deciding what to do
well
um that's a good good set of questions
I mean hopefully you know you really
like this person and you find them you
know compatible with you in in more than
just like hey I want to get it on
or you know we like the same TV shows
um you know you bring up values you want
to see whether you have similar values
to that person unless you just want to
get laid you know uh and then then move
on in which case you don't you don't
need that quite so much but I mean if
you're considering having like a real
relationship with the person
and developing genuine intimacy which is
one of the things that sex allows you to
do right but not exclusively
um then you you've gotta you gotta have
a lot in common you know when it comes
to the things that really matter and and
some and it's not just like high level
values like what do I think about
Society it's down to stuff like you know
do I look at money in the same way or do
I do I look at are what what it means to
be in a relationship the same way what
are the expectations with the uh the
other person so those are really quite
important and I suppose you know this is
one of those sort of things too where
it is important
to every once in a while like take stock
and reevaluate this sort of thing you
know if you're if you're not marrying
somebody but you're just beginning a
relationship you are not committing to
them forever and ever whatever you know
they happen to do that comes later later
on if you decide to do that sort of
thing you know
all right um
Angel how can someone direct their
personal philosophy study so it's
practically and psychologically
beneficial
started reading it recreationally but
there's too much to cover to get the
bigger names well then you know that's
good that you have that realization
there's too much to cover to read
everybody you as a matter of fact can
only read really just like you know a
sliver in in your lifetime you're not
going to be able to read all the big
names even in your lifetime and half of
what you read you're going to forget
after you've read it so you're gonna
have to go back to it so you know what I
would say is at this point if you're
like beginning or you're you know
couple years in pick a few you know
people or movements or approaches
and you know just keep reading around in
them and it might turn out that you pick
the wrong ones for you because you know
not everybody necessarily enjoys the
same thinkers but you won't know that
until you actually get into it uh and
this is this is you could say part of
the issue with studying it really
anything I mean you could say this about
literature you could say this about what
which historians and which historical
periods you're going to read what music
are you going to listen to you can't do
it all so you just pick what you think
works well for you what you respond to
and then you know I've been using this
word a lot over this this AMA
recalibrate you know
you get into it for a couple months take
stock and say
am I getting out of this would I really
want to
um or maybe should I move on to somebody
else you know
all right
um I just skipped a little bit
uh Paul says are you familiar with the
movies of Terence Malik I've run into
them recently and found them to be of
particular interest if so what are your
thoughts I'm familiar with them but I
haven't watched any for for a long time
I actually haven't watched any movies
for a long time mostly TV shows
um and I think the reason is because it
tends to be like me and my wife watching
shows like at dinner and a movie is
pretty long and a show is not quite so
long or I'm watching shows as I'm going
to bed you know I can't think of the
last actual movie I oh I I I think I do
know what the last actual movie I saw
the new Dune movie when it came out so
it's been a while
um
all right Sierra bit of a cheaper
question what is the most controversial
philosopher you find interesting or
substantial even if you frequently
disagree with them
yeah that's a good question I mean
it kind of depends on what you mean by
controversial
um I mean just about every philosophical
position is controversial in the sense
that like somebody disagrees with it and
argues about it
um
so
I mean
if we're thinking about it in terms of
like making
claims that people engage with and
disagree with
maybe Hume I mean I really do like
reading Hume and he really did stir
stuff up
um many people are still influenced by
some of his views today
you know in ethics and and
um
epistemology and things like that
there's things about his work that I
really do enjoy
um but I I you know I think he's wrong
about a lot of stuff but I'd really like
teaching him and and working on him so
all right uh August asks me if I add to
Depot do I have thoughts on on John Wall
yeah good scholar uh somebody well worth
checking out important for early
reception of Kierkegaard and uh
the 20th century French milieu
um it's kind of ignored these days I
would say there's not a lot of people
who
do work on him you know so
um
yeah
all right uh dark pianist somebody told
me truth is just systems from atoms like
H2O to biology the strongest systems
evolve and persist to create reality and
be become complex over time does this
seem likely
uh I mean as likely as any other like
thing that somebody's pulling out of
their ass basically and speculating
about I mean these giant sweeping
declarations like that I mean whenever
somebody says something like that you
got to be like well how in the hell
would you know that that's actually the
case you know given that we see this
tiny little window of what it is that we
grasp you're going to make
generalizations about everything and
human beings throughout all time that
seems a little you know uh bold to me
this by the way is where Hume would come
in and say yeah man uh not quite so sure
about that right
um truth is just systems truth is a
whole bunch of different things so I'd
I'd be wary of anybody who says truth is
only I would be on my guard with them
right
Dean says is there a distinction between
the world and my world and
wittgenstein's tractatus
um you know I don't remember it's been
more than 20 years since I've cracked
open the tractatus so there probably is
a proposition in there where he makes a
distinction between it I mean the way
that vickenshine thinks of the world is
states of Affairs meaning like you got
objects and they're connected in certain
ways and we can represent that through
language and we can to go back to an
earlier question about logic we can
determine the truth values of those
propositions there's you know like the
middle of the tractatus is actually like
a little logic treaties
um but you know Wittgenstein very
famously says that things like ethics or
Aesthetics or religion can't be
productively spoken about and those are
matters of values and presumably values
do exist in our are you know encountered
in some way but he has a hell of a time
explaining how that happens right so I
guess you could say you know your world
would be like the bit of the world that
you get to see right
all right
um
Oroville I know the answer to this
question is something really obvious I'm
just not getting if Plato endorses lying
myths like in the Republic shouldn't his
work be viewed with extra scrutiny no
because uh who's who's saying that Plato
you know says that everything that that
he's telling you is a lie or a myth
right
um I think
if you're going to apply that sort of
logic then you shouldn't trust anybody
and then you shouldn't spend any time
engaging in any sort of thought right
um you want to be more careful about
that sort of thing
I mean who who endorses the noble lie is
it Plato is it Socrates
um
you know what's the purpose of it is he
endorsing lying in general no because
already in book one of The Republic he
says that lying is one of the things
that's Injustice it doesn't he
um stems from Injustice
so you know
I wouldn't worry over much about that
um
oh Ben follows up about the Epstein
thing uh Chomsky Justified his
association with Epstein I would be
surprised if Chomsky had Justified his
association with Epstein by saying that
he had paid his debts to society because
at the time that Chomsky was associating
with Epstein Epstein had not been
arrested so that wouldn't make any sense
I mean if that's the case then maybe
Chomsky is you know
senile or something I don't know
all right Ian says sir is it nonsense to
be interested in dialectical logic yet
not be interested at all in hegel's
system of thought seems like he is an
unavoidable read just want to know how
to think dialectically well there's lots
of different dialectics right so you
know you've dialectic already is a term
back in Plato and Aristotle you find
Aristotle talking about it in the topics
which is about how to argue
dialectically and think through things
dialectically
um you know obviously we go on and Hegel
is an important figure in that
um and you can read them or not read
them that's up to you you know I mean if
you want to understand what people who
are referring to Hegel are talking about
it probably would help to know something
about Hegel I I would assume right
um
but there's you know I'm not sure why
you'd be particularly interested in
dialectical logic unless you're like
coming at it as a Marxist or something
like that because those are those are
the main people that are talking in
terms of dialectical logic I think in
the present
um and then you know marks
does you know connect with Hegel a lot
so maybe it'd be useful
all right uh Jake have you ever felt
yourself in ruts in philosophy where you
feel unenthused by it but nevertheless
see the value how would you suggest one
get back on track that's a great
question yeah I have actually
and sometimes it's
um feeling like am I really getting
anywhere with this what's the point of
what I'm doing it's kind of like an
existential crisis about philosophy
itself you know what good is what I'm
doing here
um
and you know
there isn't any like
easy remedy for that you just gotta keep
working at it until something changes
and usually that's something changing
for me was like
seeing that there was an application for
what it was that I was
um studying teaching researching
and then I'd be like oh yeah yeah I get
it now this this this is helpful this
works you know
um
but uh that's it I mean
what else could draw a person out of
that that's that's a really great
question
sometimes we get kind of bored and
dissatisfied and maybe sometimes what we
need to do then is
take a little break and do something
different like
um
you know it could be reading something
else like I enjoy reading uh
um
short stories and novels and stuff like
that by the way you know who else really
loved that GE more he read much more
novels than philosophy and actually
thought that it was not a good thing
that he was doing that but uh he really
took enjoyment in novels
um but it could be other things as well
you know getting out taking a walk in
nature
um doing sports you know exercising in
my case going in the other room and
picking up my banjo and playing and
singing you know various songs or
working on some of my techniques those
are all things that can help me come
back and then be like yeah okay now I
can reread some Descartes and teach the
stuff and not feel like it's a boring
all right
um black prairie philosophical text for
guidance on love and starting
relationships
well I mean there's a lot of stuff in
ancient philosophy right you know if
you're talking about starting romantic
relationships as opposed to Friendship
there's a bit less
on that
um
but uh
you know Aristotle stuff and Nick and
McCann ethics and udamian ethics
about friendship does actually discuss
erotic relationships
interestingly the stoics had some
thoughts about erotic relationships
because the sages yeah rotikos you know
so and then you know of course the
Symposium is is pretty awesome too isn't
it uh and then we don't proceed onward I
mean there's stuff there's a lot more
stuff I would say in like the
18th and 19th and 20th Century I mean
here's just one thing I'm just kind of
pulling out of the air
um you know Mary Wollstonecraft who I
think a lot of you have heard me talk
about before because I'm a big fan of
hers in her Vindication of the rights of
women she has some like really in-depth
discussions about what should a
relationship
be oriented by should it be primarily
about erotic desire
and all the other things that go with it
like attractiveness and you know making
yourself accommodating to the other
person
or should you be trying to develop
something like friendship you know and
and she argues for it but she's also
somebody who who did uh get involved
with that that Gilbert Imlay uh American
adventurer guy got knocked up by him
um
she didn't marry you know William Godwin
later on and had another child with him
who you all know is Mary Shelley right
uh author Frankenstein
um so she didn't completely live up to
her own stuff but there's some really
interesting Reflections there right
all right
um
Luca Olaf uh olario as a Catholic how do
you deal with some of the more frowned
upon teachings of the church such as its
views on same-sex relations
um well the church doesn't have views
people articulate views within the
church and then other people replicate
those views within the church
there's there's no such thing anymore as
there is like science with a capital S
as a the the church as an agent with a
Capital C
um and you know I I tend to like I said
before if people are concerned with that
then I want to see how much concern they
have with the stuff that scripture
actually talks much more about like
divorce and lust or something that that
the scripture talks even more about and
is discussed way way more within
tradition
um greed and money
and what we call you know social justice
so you know the way I deal with it is
sort of a prioritization I don't really
give a about
most of the stuff that Catholics get
worked up about because if you're not
enacting if you're not living up to The
Sermon on the Mount all the rest of it
is just and I don't care
and you know you look at the hierarchy
within the church at present a lot of
the Bishops are basically cowards and
corrupt and you know you look at the all
these Catholics that are essentially not
really Catholic but just right
right-wing culture Warriors
um a lot of them are basically
anti-christian uh if you go by what you
know Christian teaching is is
fundamentally about so to me it's a
non-issue
um it's it's uh it's so low on the level
of priorities compared to the stuff that
really much more fundamentally matters
that I don't worry about it
Darth Vader I'm in high school with no
philosophy classes available at my
school and I'm interested in philosophy
but I find it hard to learn on my own do
you have any tips for somebody learning
on their own
um as a matter of fact I have a whole
sequence of videos
self-directed study right there's an
entire playlist
uh which it contains some you know
advice about how to do philosophy
generally and you know about like if you
want to study Plato here's what to do if
you want to see the Aristotle you want
to study Hegel you want to study
Descartes so you know you might take a
look at that
um yeah I mean most high schools in the
United States don't have philosophy
classes or philosophy content at all and
typically don't have philosophy clubs
um so you know in Europe in other places
oftentimes you do have philosophy
classes but they might be good or they
might not be good you know
so you know you you do have some
extremely valuable opportunities
given that we have the internet right so
you can access all these cool resources
you can find communities online that you
can join in you can find all sorts of
reading groups and
um you know
free classes and stuff like that there's
there's a great number of resources and
you might actually meet people online I
mean I've got so many friends that I am
connected with
um and I've only like some of them I've
never been in the same room with them
some of them I've only seen them once in
my life but we've connected you know
over philosophy a good example is my uh
friend and colleague Harold coveley who
is the current editor of stoicism today
he was my assistant editor and took over
for me and we meet you know sometimes we
meet every week sometimes like in in
times like this where we're both kind of
busy every other week and we chat for
you know an hour on Skype um all those
sorts of things are possibilities for
you and if you go online
if depending on where you live you may
actually find like local meetup groups
that are interested at least in some
philosophy you know like you probably
don't want to go to the Ein Rand group
you know unless you're really into her
sort of schtick but you may find like a
stoic Fellowship near you or
um other cool stuff like death cafes
where you you go in and you just have in
an unstructured way talk with people
about death so there's lots and lots of
opportunities for being connected with
other people who who take an interest in
in philosophy
all right uh diogeny is the cynic after
I've gone through your start phase in
your 20s do you still Harbor a soft spot
for being in nothingness do you think do
you think it's still worthwhile to read
I know it's difficult to answer but I'd
like your take yeah I think being
nothing this is a great work I mean it's
got its flaws like any work right but
it's it's well worth reading I I think
that you know sart is a very interesting
uh philosopher and being a nothingness
is the really important early work and
uh you know I think I I may have said
this before but so the half hour Hegel
project I will be able to you know ever
all things being equal I'll be able to
finish that up this summer
and then the question is what am I doing
after that
so
I've already applied the half hour Hegel
methodology of this close reading half
an hour at a time you know reading the
text then then commenting on it to
epictetuses and caridian and there's two
other fairly short works that I intend
to apply this to as well one of them is
Descartes meditations
and the other one is Saint Anselm's pros
logian and then it'll be time for
another big book
and you know like the phenomenology like
about that thickness well I think being
in nothingness is probably the book that
I'll do that with
because I think it could use a
commentary and it's still you know it's
still red it's still referenced so yeah
um rock lock what is your favorite book
or resource to learn the most important
principles of analytic thinking I don't
know what the principles of analytic
thinking are so I don't have any idea
about that
um
all right let's see here
sauceless Giuseppe
I guess it's just pasta then right what
are your thoughts feeling and opinion of
Heidegger so you know Heidegger
um
put aside the Nazi stuff for for a bit
right we'll come back to that
um Heidegger's a great philosopher he's
got some really interesting
contributions like a lot of philosophers
of his time and all the way going back
to Hegel he's he's got a screwed up take
on the value of Hellenistic philosophy
uh you know things like Plato and
Aristotle and the presocratics that's
the real game in town and he he
basically doesn't think that the later
thinkers are as valuable as they they
actually are and so that that's a flaw
in his his work but he's got some really
interesting insights and ideas that he
he develops that I think we don't want
to reject just because of the
insufficiencies of what he's doing and
you know when you look at not just like
being in time in these various essays
that that he writes that get bundled
into different works but you look at his
um his lectures there's actually a lot
of really cool stuff in there depending
on which one you're you're looking at
he usually I will say this about the
lectures very often he doesn't actually
talk about what the title of the lecture
would seem to be right
um but you know you get some cool
insights out of him anyway now the Nazi
thing right Heidegger was a Nazi he
joined the Nazi party he uh
um turned against his his uh mentor
hussarel and
um
he you know he doesn't appear to have uh
been
you know committed in in a full sense
but
um it certainly does taint some of his
his work right uh should we reject him
entirely because of that I don't think
so
um but we should say you know
we we definitely don't want to go down
the path that he went right so
all right uh
reflective Journey Plato just wants his
readers to be 140 plus IQ big deal you
know anytime that somebody talks about
IQ I automatically lose respect for them
these days and I assume that they're not
very smart no matter what their numbers
are
um so IQ is probably you know I'm
assuming that you're joking around about
it
um and that you're you actually are
pretty smart but whenever I see people
like resting anything on IQ I'm like
well there's there's a stupid person
clearly
um because it doesn't mean anything I
mean you can have a high IQ which means
that you tested well that day you know
or perhaps a couple other days in the
things that IQ measures but it doesn't
measure actual intelligence you know
all right uh lapse nine Continuum uh
what is your stance on the universalism
versus nominalism debate do you lean
more towards one side or the other
perhaps that whole framework and it is
right is abstract and oversimplified it
is abstract in over 7
and there isn't really a debate
um it's a topic and there are people
like you could say
pushing you know a whatever you want to
call it universalism platonism realism
you know versus nominalism uh which has
also gone by different names there's
different people exemplifying bits and
pieces of that there are very few people
out there that are like saying I enter
the lists as the nominalist versus you
know and then here comes the other guy I
am the plate in uh the in a platonic
realist or something like that there
isn't there isn't much of that actually
going on I mean there are some things we
probably want to be nominalist about and
there's other things we probably want
not to be nominalists about because you
know nominalism taken to its extreme
it's kind of self-defeating isn't it but
there you know there's there's various
things for which it kind of works right
um
all right John has another Heidegger
thing have you read any of Heidegger's
lectures on hilderin the Easter
remembrance Etc what do you think of
them and where do you think they should
stand within the wider context of
Heidegger's thinking yeah I mean I've
read stuff
um by Heidegger on hilderin I'm not a
huge fan of hilderin uh and it's one of
those things where
I mean maybe it is very important to his
work but I don't consider it so I think
you could perfectly easily read being in
time or the nature lectures or you know
um plenty of these other essays without
worrying about what Heidegger thinks of
this this particular German poet
um so you know and I'd be more inclined
to pay attention to what he has to say
about like say rilka but
um
yeah I mean some people really get into
them my wife does actually and she's
she's somebody who's studied a lot of
Heidegger and she likes herder in quite
a bit
um I just it's never really like gripped
for me so I I'm probably not a good
person to answer that you know
Max Montague says uh just wanted to say
thank you very much for all your work
I'm now about to graduate college of the
minor in philosophy excellent that
that's great
um I'm glad that uh you were able to
find you know people to study with
that's really awesome and yeah that's
that's wonderful
oh it just skipped again ah Cola moose
is there anything you would you would
say
contrasting perhaps a sort of
psychoanalytic view on love and someone
like Plato
um
I mean depends on which psychoanalytic
point of view we're using most
psychoanalysts have read Plato
and you know it depends on what we're
talking about with Plato are we talking
about like the Symposium are we talking
about the different sorts of being filo
something fond of something as often how
it's translated in in
um I want to say Republic book six
yeah I think it's six or maybe it's five
um or are we you know what are we
actually talking about I think
we have to specify there
um
you can say this
Plato thinks
very clearly
that
love desire Eros is an important feature
of our existence
and then it does drive us and it can be
here's here's a psychoanalytic term
sublimated right it can be transformed
into something higher and a
psychoanalysts at least if they're
following Freud and they're not like
going off into something
uh
you know like ego pure ego psychology or
something like that and they think that
that Eros libido is something
Central to our development and our
desires and our relationships then
um you could say that part of what the
psychoanalytic approach was was to like
figure out how to deal with these crazy
feelings that we have and transform them
into something we can live with and not
you know be too much of a pain to
everybody else about
but there's different
[Music]
um
there's different ways of doing this and
we always have to like
reassess as as time goes on with that
you know
all right
um
let's see here
reflective Journey asks do you prefer
relation first ontology or substance
first ontology neither do you think qm
points towards relation first ontology
um I'm not quite sure what qm stands for
the first thing that comes to mind for
me is quality matters which is a you
know a set of uh standards that we use
in an organization for online teaching
um
I mean I think it depends on what you're
trying to an ontology is like a you know
saying what what exists what is the case
what what is real uh it depends on what
kind of thing you're talking about
um if you're talking about a friendship
obviously that's a relation if you think
that we exist within the Matrix of
relations then you have some relation
first ontology there if you think that
you know substances matter then you've
got a substance based ontology why why
do we have to choose between the two
rather than recognizing that reality is
really complicated and probably
interviews both of these together
yeah
um Elijah says
on love Blondell seems to say as Maurice
Blondell that courage is needed for
vulnerability wisdom for trust and
Temperance for devotion and the
respective Rewards or the beloveds hope
faith and love do I misinterpret I don't
know where he said that that doesn't
ring a bell with me so
um I I can't really tell you anything
about that right
um that's not a a passage that
particularly gripped me whenever if I
ever did come across it
um
see uh something something something
where should I start with glycerol
typically when I'm teaching what's wrong
yeah and it's been a long time since I
have
um because I found students don't really
like westerol much
um what I'll usually do is is I'll have
them read the Cartesian meditations
which is nice and short
it's very technical but it's it's at
least like it's easier to make sense of
and then I'll have them read
um whistle's article on phenomenology
from the Encyclopedia Britannica where
he's talking about his his work you know
all right
um
online person is anxiety one of the
pains that Aristotle would want us to
orient ourselves appropriately towards
in order to live virtuously
was what what their a similar concept at
the time was there a similar concept at
the time so anxiety
um in Greek would you usually the term
we would use for that is agonia
and that as far as I know it doesn't
show up in Aristotle Aristotle talks
about Phobos fear
and the
Danos the scary
um
but he doesn't talk about
what we often distinguish against fear
as as anxiety in in the present and
um
anxiety wouldn't be a pain it would be
an emotion right so emotions the pathway
are something distinct from just pain
Lupe they can be painful but that
doesn't make them a pain all right
um
so I this is kind of a non-starter you
know if you want to see what Aristotle
has to say about the emotions
uh the places you want to go to would be
rhetoric book two where he's not
discussing all of the emotions because
he does talk about other emotions that
aren't uh mentioned there for example
Nick and McCain ethics book
nine you know the friend shares our Joys
and our griefs our pothos
um and you can look in the McCain ethics
there it's more in terms of a virtue
ethics context right but the virtues are
concerned with not just actions peroxis
but also with our feelings or emotions
but he doesn't he doesn't talk he talks
about fear but not anxiety and such
um
let's see
tm1 do you know of any other books of
wisdom like a Book of Proverbs in the
book of Ben Sorak
yeah I mean if you're talking about
um the wisdom literature in the Bible so
you've actually got something you know
there is the the wisdom of Ben Sorak is
what it's called and then there's the
wisdom that's often called The Book of
wisdom or the wisdom of Solomon and if
you're if you're using a Protestant
Bible you're not going to find those
because Martin Luther took them out
um but if you're using any of the Bibles
of the earlier churches Catholic
Orthodox Coptic Syriac you know Syrian
Church of the East Armenian those will
be in there because they were they were
part of the original Canon
um The Book of Psalms is considered a
sapiential book so you know that's what
we're thinking about as you mentioned
Proverbs already there's Ecclesiastes
Book of Job right which is a wonderful
philosophical dialogue that's that's a
sapiential book weirdly enough the song
of songs which is erotic poetry
essentially is considered a wisdom book
you got to do a lot of interpretation
with that don't you
um so I mean those are the things that
are in there and then you know there's
all sorts of great
post you know scriptural stuff that um
you could read you know we talked about
early Christian philosophers at the
beginning of this AMA session so you
know people like Clement of Alexandria
definitely in a sapiential space or
lockedancius uh Justin Martyr you know
the these these great thinkers
um
John did you watch the coronation no I
didn't watch the coronation I don't care
about the British Monarchy at all I find
it weird that the that British people do
but then again you know British people
find it weird that we care about NFL
football which uh if you think about in
the long scheme of things is about as
trivial as the British Monarchy
um
just I don't I don't watch crap like
that I I mean I watch crap like NFL
football I don't watch crap like the
British coronation
uh Dominic have you read Vonnegut is
there something you would recommend yeah
I mean I've read Vonnegut when I was in
college
um
I mean
there's nothing I would recommend
because I haven't read him for
more than two decades so
all right
um
Felipe says if you could have anything
right now
what would it be
what that's that's a great question sort
of like saying if you could have one
wish
I mean if we're talking like really
really big picture
I would say
um
you know an end to exploitation and
people threatening each other and the
the environment that we live in where
you could just walk down the wrong
Street and get shot by some crazy gun
Nutter person or you know get beaten up
or stuff like that
um I mean if it has to be closer to home
I would say
um good health and body and mind for my
wife and my kids
um
if it has to be something for me
you know
um
that I lived to 80
rather than getting hit by the bus uh
or getting sick and dying you know
earlier because I got a lot of stuff to
do so all right
um
let's see if let's pick somebody who I
haven't
done before because we're getting closer
to the top of the hour
um
Hamza says what's your opinion on
bianchul Han's work I haven't read it so
that I can't have an opinion
um
Angel says a student asked how do you
know something is true the Prof asked
the prophet answered if it coincides
with reality seems circular is this a
good answer and how would you answer
well like I mentioned before truth is
not a thing that it's not a term that
has just one meaning there's more than
one way of being true the professor
actually gave a good answer for one
Theory or approach to truth what we call
the correspondence theory which says
that truth is a
correspondence between what's in our
mind or what we say and what is in
reality this goes all the way back to
Aristotle you know it's actually even
earlier than that
but Aristotle kind of you know
formulates this
um so I think it's fine it's just it's
not a sufficient
definition of truth there's there's more
types of Truth you know so we can talk
about uh other theories we can talk
about other treatments of Truth you know
great example you know
there's there's a whole dialogue by
ansem called on Truth where he talks
about truth in thought and expression
which kind of looks like that uh and
then truth in action in the will truth
and the being of things right so
um there's there's that Heidegger has
alethea unveiling on you know on
concealing as truth
um you know the pragmatists have their
own interesting speculations on truth so
yeah
all right
um
Rock lock says
for example
principles such as sample size
extrapolation correlation versus
causational Having learned these
principles one's analytic thinking is
hindered any thoughts on books I'm not
sure what all that is supposed to mean
thoughts on books about
these principles there's lots of books
out there just get a textbook
um
all right uh
uh Paul Jackson and philosophy is a good
point it seems like whatever position
one comes to there will always be a lot
of wicked smart people who totally
disagree but it also seems like I should
adjust my beliefs to account for the
differing beliefs of those who I respect
intellectually how do these thoughts
reconcile with difficulty
and it's an ongoing process now there
yeah there may be some people that
strike you as being Wicked smart uh do
they totally disagree usually there's
there's no such thing as total
disagreement
um they'll disagree on this thing but
not this thing over here so maybe look
for where there's some agreement and
then you know you you gotta like pick
who you're going to to uh work with you
know
uh whose point of view you're going to
to accept
um
Darth Vader do you have any tips for
when you're reading a philosophy book
but you're stuck and don't understand
what you're reading
yeah I mean if you have the luxury of
not having to like present it or take a
test on it put it down and uh leave it
alone for a while and maybe read a
different philosopher or you know
um
read some other literature or go take a
walk or stuff like that I mean it might
be helpful you know if you've got
reliable secondary sources
to uh go see what other people have to
say about it because sometimes it can be
just like you're not getting the
terminology like when you're reading
Kant for example right Kant loves his
jargon and sometimes the way that he
uses the jargon when it's translated
into English we're like well that
doesn't mean what I think it means does
it
so you know that could be um
that could be kind of helpful I think
um
you know there's lots and lots of
resources out there the the trouble is
of course that you don't know which
resources are really reliable because
you you know they're they're they're
saying I have the interpretation of this
text over here and you're like I can't
make sense of this text so how do you
know that they're getting it right I
mean it is tough to tell but I would say
you know just just keep at it don't
don't stress yourself out over it too
much
um the world is not gonna end if you
can't make sense out of what hegel's
saying in some passage right
um and you can always that's the nice
thing about books you can always come
back to them right
[Music]
um
VV says not a question but a long time
follower from when I had less than 10
000 followers have enjoyed and
appreciated your lectures and your work
ethic is out of this world and has been
highly inspiring oh that thanks that's
very nice I mean I just keep grinding
away at it you know and I've been
fortunate in that I get to teach a lot
of classes and I use my my videos for
those classes so having classes gives me
an opportunity to shoot a lot of like
core concept videos for example you know
like this last Academic Year teaching at
Marquette this new core class that they
have that I I chose to focus on anger
I've gotten to shoot videos on like
Aristotle and Thomas Aquinas and lot
tonsis and John Cassian and Bishop
Butler and you know all these other
people talking about uh anger in their
works and then other you know related
things oh here's an interesting one for
Brock Covington as half hour Hegel comes
to a close what are your biggest
takeaways from Hegel and making the
series any future projects of a similar
structure so I did mention I I do have
you know
I already did a similar project with
epictetuses and caridian and I'm
planning on doing it with Descartes
meditations and Anselm's Pro slogan and
then you know probably starts uh being
in nothingness
but yeah takeaways
um
so you know I did this whole video a
little while back on texts with aura I
think there's a lot of people who feel
like you know whether it's like
Spinoza's ethics or hegel's
phenomenology or const critique of pure
reason there are these books that are
like absolutely important to read and
they're like super difficult and you
know if you could just like understand
them everything would make sense and I I
think I kind of underestimated how
strong that sentiment is out there
um
among so many people
and people stress themselves out about
that you know
um I mean I also it's been good doing
this very close reading and going back
over the text time and time again
because there's things where I'm like
yeah Hegel
he's kind of he's good on this but he's
full of it on this you know
um I mean like his clearly history
didn't end you know
um when we're trying to talk about like
the structure of the phenomenology why
does it go why does it Zig here instead
of zagging you know uh there's certain
areas where you're like come on here you
go like he gets stoicism and skepticism
wrong but it's always interesting stuff
along the way right and I've actually
been considering writing a book once I
finish up with the the series
um about what it is that I think is
valuable in Hegel like his his analysis
in the phenomenology of moral action in
the spirit sections is actually I think
very interesting and and quite good you
know
all right uh let's see I'm gonna finish
up
let's see if there's a good one to
finish up with
um
so here's kind of a funny one from Paul
Chachi pts Dr Sadler which philosophy or
philosopher do you find most applicable
to everyday life for lifelong Learners
and why as a human I'd be interested as
well but that that is a tough one
um
one single philosopher who's most
applicable to Everyday Life
I mean I can tell you who
would kind of fit in there
you know Epictetus
Aristotle
[Music]
um
I mean maybe David Hume in some respects
um but I I'm gonna go with Aristotle
actually although you know there's so
much that Aristotle doesn't discuss
you know if if we could include a
philosopher and their followers
then maybe it would be Plato right
because we have this vast platonic
tradition coming out of plate but that's
kind of that's probably cheating isn't
it so
all right
um
let's see if there's any oh yeah so
here's a good one to go out on uh Mason
asks what's your favorite Lightfoot song
I Like The Wreck of the Edmund
Fitzgerald which is a lovely song I
cannot play and sing it myself without
crying
and I actually there's another one that
I I can't at this point get through
without uh tearing up not not like
listening to it but actually like
playing it and singing it and it's
Willow's cattails
and the reason I'm gonna do some writing
about this is because it reminds me so
much of my childhood living out about 30
miles west of here in the countryside
in the woods and Meadows and marshes
and traipsing along with my parents and
um
you know
spending time in the
in in that kind of Nature and it also
reminds me of my parents both of whom
died far too young
and the time that what it must have been
like for them as adults living and
loving and forming a life together
and it's just such a lovely song
you know I mean there's so many other
songs by by
um Gordon Lightfoot that I really do
love he was a great Lyricist very
thoughtful man and uh great musician but
so that's where we'll uh we'll end up
today my my wife just came in she's got
a sandwich for me that I gotta eat
before my next event thanks for all of
you uh hanging out with me for this time
and good uh good questions and uh food
for thought about something so I will
see you down the line I will mention too
that I've got a I've got online classes
coming up if you're interested this
summer
uh I've already got the Aristotle ones
which starts May 25th lined up and I
will be doing another one on Descartes
meditations uh objections and replies
starting on the 25th as well so if you
you know you can see stuff about that in
the channel
um all right I will see all of you
someday in The Ether
foreign